hey guys come here weird another GSU's
update for you now I can be a pain to
hang around with but I'm not the worst
company in America and you know who else
isn't EI yup pa turns out won't renamed
worst company in America for the third
year running denying them that
particularly unenviable Trinity first
round voting is underway in The
Consumerist
annual bracket challenge and ei lost to
the Time Warner company by a narrow
margin of fifty one point two percent to
forty eight point eight percent better
luck next year guys The Consumerist cold
at battlefield fours rocky launch as a
shortcoming for EA in the past year as
well as the release of titanfall earlier
this month a lot to fight might raise
some eyebrows though as Titan Souls
release largely went off without a hitch
whatever the case EA will not take home
the golden pure award this year so who
will win this prestigious award now EA
are out of the running Microsoft
Facebook C world let me know in the
comments down below and for all your
other gaming news just head on over to
gain spot calm